it's time for ETS late-night roundup
your quick catch up on all the best
celebrity scoop after dark
meri dag ill angel spike pretender sarah
michelle gellar got a bit nostalgic on
tuesdays watch what happens live with
Andy Cohen reminiscing on her Buffy the
Vampire Slayer days Mary angel but can
you really marry the undead I guess okay
so Mary angel you shagged spike
obviously kill Xander though we just
Gellar also reflected on her crazy ones
co-star the late Robin Williams
I never took for granted every moment
that even being present in the moment at
the time because he was spectacular were
you aware of his inner turmoil that's
about him I mean that just yeah I rest
over on The Tonight Show Jimmy Fallon
and Blake Shelton brought the laughs
hilariously poking fun at one another
during a tour of Jimmy's new ride at
Universal Studios Orlando Florida Jay
Leno here see this is this is when the
show was good right here it's the
ragtime yeah guys do you know anything
Blake Shelton songs meanwhile James
Corden Claire Danes Jack McBrayer and
Christine Baranski teamed up on The Late
Late Show for another installment of the
bold and the lyrical this time with Katy
Perry lyrics I confess
I kissed a girl I liked it
that's what you get for waking up in
Vegas
you